[Music]
you have got three films at Sundance at
the same time this year you had three
films at Sundance that's kind of unheard
that must be a record of some kind well
the craziest part was they all happened
to premiere on the same day which put me
in the position of having to say the
douchiest thing of all time when
somebody who's the douchiest I can't
wait to hear the douchiest thing of all
time get ready where somebody would be
like oh I did such a great job in your
film congratulations and I would have to
say which one there's no way around but
it's an awful thing to say yeah
fantastic
so making friends all over the country
speaking of friends you're very good
friends with Aubrey Plaza very funny and
talented our booth yeah yeah you guys
take spur-of-the-moment vacations
together I'm told yes she she called me
like one night and was like do you want
to go to Mexico tomorrow and she's a
weirdo so I was like this will be great
and we went to Mexico together and I
thought that a fun game to play in the
airport because we had this escort
through the airport a fun game to play
would be that whenever anybody came up
to one of us to say that they were a fan
of our work that I would tell the escort
that she should say something nice to
Aubree because Aubree gets really
jealous of how famous I am and so how
did that go not well
Aubree did not appreciate know as she
was cool about it I mean but basically
every time that somebody else would come
up and say that she they loved her on
the show or they loved me and something
like the other person would act really
really hurt and petulant and in front of
the fans yeah she's a weirdo it was
great Yuri you were doing it too you
were the one yeah so it's it's on you as
well I can blame her because she's more
publicly weird
the Katy Perry things out you've got
your own problems